letzte vorbereitungen zum saison-start
neue attraktionen für den kulturpark
einsiedel in der oberlausitz übernachten
den baumhäusern und baden im neuen
wellnessbereich der etwas anderen art
das ist das konzept mit dem der chef
jürgen bergmann mehr touristen in dieser
ländliche region locken will 100.000 pro
jahr kommen bisher 150 1000 sollen es
werden
prinzipiell muss alles professionell
genug sein damit es funktioniert ist
klar
und das ist unser faulenzen was hier
gerade entsteht wir haben also einen
jetzt letzten jahr das probiert das
funktioniert und jetzt wird es
professioneller damit es eben auch
wirtschaftlich sinnvoll ist und das ist
so unsere touristische wellnessanlage da
sitzt man dann sozusagen bis zu zehn im
kannibalen kessel und lässt sich da gar
kopf schöne landschaften und orte hat
die oberlausitz zu bieten aber
international völlig unbekannt wie auch
die stadt bautzen mit ihren 40.000
einwohnern die brunnen sind festlich
geschmückt ein sich die besucher fehlen
noch
potsdams oberbürgermeister verbreitet
internationales flair hat jahrelang in
china gelebt er meint die stadt hat sich
einfach nicht gut genug in szene gesetzt
wenn das thema auf boxen kommt dann
fällt den leuten vielleicht noch der
stasi knast ein manchen noch der senf
und das master dass wir hier eine der
schönsten städte deutschlands haben mit
einer komplett erhaltenen altstadt
unheimlich wirtschaftsstarken und auch
sehenswerten region ist so gut wie
niemandem bekannt und da müssen wir
tatsächlich noch einiges nachholen
serbische traditionen sollen mehr
besucher bringen
der kulturverein druckt tänze und
gesänge das tanzensemble war schon in 45
ländern der welt auf tournee
nun sollen die dortigen zuschauer auch
mal in die oberlausitz kommen der
tourismuschef sieht in der sorbischen
kultur großes potenzial hat einen großen
kulturellen wert und hat auch lange
tradition und diese wollen wir pflegen
die deutschen die sorgen gemeinsam aber
natürlich auch im sinne für die
touristische entwicklung für unsere
regionen
denn es ist ein alleinstellungsmerkmal
von dem wir wirklich sehr viel
versprechen zurück nach einsiedeln
hier setzen die nicht nur auf tourismus
dennoch kommt zu wenige in den
abgelegenen landstrich in der
hauseigenen holzwerkstatt ford-werk man
stattdessen freizeitanlagen für
frankreich und den europapark rust die
produktion bei uns das ist macht uns
besonders wir reißen damit bakterien
ganz westeuropa um und bauen für die
freizeiteinrichtung für andere
freizeiteinrichtungen und das macht mehr
als zwei dritteln ungefähr dreiviertel
jahr also letztes jahr waren es ungefähr
viereinhalb millionen also es ist schon
eine größenordnung und ist unser
standbein das nächste große projekt ist
ein abenteuer hotel für einen
chinesischen investor nur durch solche
aufträge kann er seinen freizeitpark
mitfinanzieren